[Aplausos]
representa você
quando foi minha proposta de morar aqui
solar 90 agora e vou confessar que
temos alguma dificuldade em seu
exercício é necessário esta manhã
Isso me motiva a ser aquele que fez o tempo todo
quem fez isso pensar quando ele concordou
ele queria que eu me lembrasse atrás
plano de instantes hoje você pode pensar em um
convocado segue conclusão
Bem, eles são os vídeos e cogumelos
a verdade não é como assim
como eu digo tal conclusão o absurdo
era de um recurso 32 e poucas linhas e
dentado verificar um email em tavira fez
videogames motivaram tal recurso
pensei em altura quero estudar
faculdade foi a época do
internet pontocom não era um
máximo foram todas as oportunidades e hoje eu
para engenharia de telecomunicações
história de cervo e foi confirmado que era
formado no primeiro dia em que nos conhecemos
presidente da faculdade para 600 alunos
em Barcelona
estamos todos assim todos com medo e nós
diz ônibus que seremos os líderes do
sociedade hoje eu
primeiro dia da faculdade de jazz ou
líder da sociedade se terminarmos seu curso
também trabalhar muito duro durante
cinco anos muitos não dado algum
de ajuda
e no final conseguimos ser líderes
líderes desempregados em meio à crise
porque tão de repente as crianças
todos nós queremos trabalhar
telecomunicações os únicos que
Eles oferecem negócios, são consultores também.
então vou começar a fazer entrevistas
e imensas entrevistas foi a soma de
entrevistas que percebi qualquer
a coisa estava errada como estava, então estava
entrevista e entrevistador pe como
retomar
para mim eu já tenho que ver o que ele pode
acontecer hoje permite ainda mais
publicidade enganosa
como se
uma fotografia não vai cair avatar
em tudo e perceber qualquer coisa em
aquele mundo que não existe para mim e vozes sim
hit ou flyer dois bomber que o mesmo
que tirou a mesma camisa publicitária
exatamente o que eles vêem caminho
aprendi a levantar
[Aplausos]
entre a fotografia e agora a estrada quebrada
foi o que eu percebi isso não é um amigo
que não existe tal coisa para mim isso eu pensei
equipe me facilite para você pesquisar
quando fui somos um projeto final de
raça
estava experimentando comecei a enviar para
procurar documentos e encontrou um
chance de um suíço um suíço hoje
doutorado em neurociência
computação e robótica hoje e assim por diante
vamos ver se eu tenho que ser isso
certeza rede de estresse que você tem
Eu também era a neurociência de quatro anos
computacional vamos ver como
o cérebro promissor funciona o que
Eu aprendi como o cérebro funciona
mosquito
meses completos o suficiente
tez não vai pular mais em mim não é
bem-vindo vamos dar um mundo
atrás de um robô e fazer um assalto
inseto ou ser peixe último roubo inseto
quanto a ser tão grande eu rei você
inteligência eram um banheiro as paredes
isso e eu tenho 95 por cento de
os casos que e as informações que recebi
um cheque e isso não vai mudar o mundo
e isso eu quero ser qualquer outra coisa
que tem mais impacto e volta a
Barcelona o investimento foi em um
centro de estudos audiovisuais outros
começamos a trabalhar com a realidade
virtual outra coisa realidade muito difícil
virtual que muito bem fui sem tempo
em que não estimamos um projeto com
pacientes neurológicos que
tinha sofrido um derrame que todos
de repente começou a ser sentida
curso errático bizarro queria que
Eu não sabia muito pouco onde estará lá
foi sentido de estudo porque porque
começamos a trabalhar com os pacientes de
acidente vascular cerebral que tem um estado ruim
sem cérebro, portanto, um componente
neurociência central e começamos a usar
robótica assistiva de repente um inseto
tornou-se útil
e começamos a usar videogames para
auxiliar nosso processo
reabilitação
e o desafio agora é tentar convencer
que um videogame até desarma
cuja recusa pode ser uma ferramenta
inválido para ajudar esses pesos como
se a motivação da primeira colisão porque
motivação porque nossos pacientes
depois de abc a torção de um
trauma é perder habilidades muito
básicos que distinguem antes de processos
reabilitação um processo complexo e
difícil porque você é mais básico do que nós
temos feder antes não mais
recebemos e somos confrontados com um
processo de reabilitação ou falha e
atencioso não ficou tentado não entendeu
um processo difícil, portanto, o que
acontece é que muitas vezes o
pacientes saem da reabilitação porque
não estamos vendo o progresso da sua meta e
outros entram permanecem em mais estados
depressivo
embora apresentação de jogos de vídeo aqui
Vamos imaginar que temos em vez de
fazer trabalho de reabilitação
contexto hospitalar normal nos tornamos
taxas de reabilitação, você, você,
Chego de repente já estamos mais motivadores
Eu sei que ele não vai falhar mais porque ele
não eu fico entrincheirado nós somos
objetivos e tenho um filtro de exposição de
mais oleado
a primeira coisa que somos
isso abriu meus olhos não são motivadores
os que mais nos permitem
tecnologias de entretenimento uma coisa
muito importante quando vamos falar
pessoas com 16 motores adapta o som
física como se não soubéssemos o que queremos fazer
queremos fornecer mecanismos de
feedback para que essas pessoas possam
treinar suas habilidades motoras e ter
feedback positivo
tecnologias de entretenimento
armazenar dois sensores tremendamente
barato nos conseguimos usar o paraíso
se não nos tornarmos pacientes o que há
dê a si mesmo uma deficiência motora, podemos
capturar os próprios movimentos
dispositivos que jogamos videogames
agora seus pacientes estão em déficit
motor que não lhes permite ter um
movimento ativo para seus filhos mesmo
temos que recorrer ao que se chama
roubo de tecnologias assistivas ou
exoesqueletos de borracha com equipamento
ajudar a realizar o movimento
mais vezes nem sempre é possível um
movimento entra nesse caso, podemos
usar técnicas de neurofeedback que vamos
fale depois tudo bem vamos seguir em frente
e ouça como um todo
[Música]
de ferramentas que cada um dos
pacientes necessários para
para você não neste caso temos um
paciente que tem auxílio de um
robô assertivo que é fazer um
treinar ou física assim que um vídeo chegar
Eu mais do que interessante aqui
esses sensores que estamos usando para
interessados ​​hoje nos permitem perceber
por rastreamento ocular onde eu vou para o peso
com esses movimentos que fas cuja
objetos podem ser úteis para outra coisa
mas que eles têm monitorado e
quantificação quantificada é
tremendamente importante porque
pacientes estão em um processo em que
melhorar
é como se isso melhorasse isso sim
eles conseguem medir o desempenho da mina
quando passamos reabilitação muitos
Às vezes ele não consegue chegar ao escobar desde
Então vamos dar um exemplo e
é preciso muito trem ou você nos pega
pegou o diretório de progresso, mas não colocou feedback
adequado ou brisa em tudo se nós
podemos quantificar por exemplo aqui
temos um exemplo de movimento
velocidade dos braços eu vou poder
quantificar naquele momento e também não
tempo e eu posso fornecer o novo
pacientes semanas semanas nessa base são
como ser scam ser um certo
avalie isso muito importante porque o
pacientes percebem ou eu já fiz um esforço que
eu mais pontos
se for melhor eles conseguem quantificar um
algo que é muito difícil de quantificar
ambiente hospitaleiro e que se torna
agentes de reabilitação ativos porque
eles podem tomar a iniciativa e não
receptores passivos
também fato podemos quantificar
nos permite outra coisa que se adapta é
automático como eu sei se eu sei como eles devem
ser paciente e marido
adaptar uma ioga
Agora vamos ver um exemplo de um jogo que
foi projetado para treinar ou cardio
o que através deste ping e treinar ou
os dois membros superiores os olhos
ponce bastante completo neste caso
tinha parte dos membros inferiores
superiores têm a taxa cognitiva e
depois de schumacher em muitas coisas para
ser mais fácil é mais difícil
o que acontece se quisermos fazer
cultura não é ideal
temos que ser inteligentes como
estávamos prontos porque porque se eu muito
você leva simples para responder ostrava
residir não bolívar muito que não vai ser
interessante se muito difícil de terminar
frustrado meu desempenho vai ser vice
Eu tenho que procurar ele equilibrado o e isso
antes quando encontramos esse equilíbrio
somos uma área que de acordo com e é como
fluxo que um estado em que estamos
imerso no jogo não é uma taxa
e que queremos alcançar exatamente isso
pessoas totalmente dedicadas
investido nessa tentativa de exercício
passar as coisas de uma maneira melhor e para
para que eu possa te ajudar
outro componente da realidade ecológica que
tinha a ver com roubo
vamos aos passos que isso valida
ecológico, vimos um exemplo de trem ou
pobre pós cognitivo está comemorando
visto um tipo de trem ou muito usual
para reabilitação cognitiva
temos
temos um paciente que está usando um
imã em papel e lápis para fazer
uma taxa
hoje estamos falando de pacientes abc
que finalmente apresentam déficit motor e
cognitivo que continuou a ter efe sem
motor e eu já tenho interesse ir como al
planeta e isso eu não vou deixar anis depois
Eu também vou leiloar essas cartas
taxas que são claramente taxas de
treinar ou cognitivo plus que é muito desafiador
Eu tinha que ser independente em casa
eu tinha pensamentos prontos
supermercado tinha que poder ir
de casa para o supermercado e de volta eu tinha
para aumentar eu tinha um multibanco como vai
e aristo me ajuda à distância e muito
ótimo que, portanto, precisamos de estreias
que estão mais perto e o dia em que o
assaltos e realidade virtual entraram
que definimos neste caso, atingimos o
taxas que normalmente nos trazem mestres
para no papel e no lápis ter o
habilidades cognitivas nós as convertemos
em um trem ou contextualizado neste
caso em uma cidade virtual em que um
pessoa eu tenho que treinar seus
competências num contexto muito próximo
do kers van facer e eles vão especificar o que
futuro, por exemplo, navegar por uma cidade e
dos supermercados traseiros contras uso
um multi banco coisas muito turísticas mais
que são necessários para ser
vida diária independente
riqueza do que a farmácia a um conjunto de
cotações
e assim eles estão muito mais próximos ou que nós
não precisamos daquele trem ou mais
resumo
e máxima coisa que pode parecer pouco
óbvio
neurociência agora para o videogame
Também estes sensores de movimento
neurociência da realidade e aqui está
mais da diferença quando nós
consideramos princípios da neurociência
videogames vamos passo a passo o que
significa isso
por exemplo de um determinado paciente
que não tem movimento ativo não é
na capacidade de depósito de movimento para
às vezes em dois braços também existe
literatura abundante que falha seu trem ou
mental
para muitos atletas que de fato usam
isso e se imaginarmos que somos
fazer um movimento áreas de nossa
cérebro que são as mesmas que as áreas
que eu usaria parece ser um movimento
que são ativados por ambos se não mais
possui realizar um movimento imaginado
um cérebro que ugt no estado vai ser
ativado de forma semelhante e
podemos facer fez e é muito comentado
há literatura que diz que fez efeito
mais agora que acontece como foi visto
imagine bem conhecido aqui josh theater
em que contexto estou marginalizando o
vida que muito importante é por isso que quando
criamos um ambiente virtual para
fornecer feedback imagine que você
imagine ou nasa e de repente lindo um
mundo virtual que é governado e estação
De repente, tive mais feedback e um
cérebro para ser capaz de perceber o que é
acontecem para ativar mecanismos de
recompensa de reconhecimento do sono
mais este um mundo abstrato assim
funciona concretamente
usamos a interface cérebro-computador
vamos à eletroencefalografia medimos
atividade aqui fora do cérebro
atividade elétrica que tentamos traduzir
a imaginação da intenção motora nesse
é que o computador para sua pessoa
e como fazemos isso se eu sou um paciente
e fisicamente eu não aconselho a realizar um
movimento vamos dar um corpo virtual
como virtual que consegue controlar
através dessa imaginação motora e por
ambos apresentam o primeiro peso a
corpo virtual que irá realizar mais
aumentos estão sempre indo para a fila para
band-aid para a esquerda para corrigir alguns
de quantas bandeiras você está falando
uma espécie de ioga
e como funciona temos aqui uma pessoa
ter um capítulo de interface é ser
capturados aos motores intensos e como
vêm as coisas acontecem o um movimento de
braços todo cérebro de cabelo controlado
não há mais movimento físico
aplicar em dois cilindros que são esses
dois cilindros vibratórios têm fitac
toque o que significa que quando é
pessoa imagina gometer braço direito
É assim que eu visualizo o braço direto de Mayer
vibração bastante decente
armas e esportes que mostramos consertam o
ciclo intenso e feedback ainda mais
hardware seu cérebro para ser capaz de
perceber o que está acontecendo
Será que vai dar certo aqui vou falar
um caso um caso poderia falar sobre casos
que não funcionam e que vou comparar
quando estávamos acostumados eu com você e
sem ter esses princípios
neurocientistas dois que fale é um
paciente que utilizou nosso sistema
durante um trem ou um mês
o início do trem ou por um mês este
re trinar tampa competiu interface e
este sistema de remo e então temos
um mês depois do trem ou vemos que
melhor do que o upline e em
linha horizontal indica ou que
clinicamente estes são anos importantes
fazer a diferença clínica
estatística 2 na clínica certificar
que alguma diferença pode falhar ou que
as atividades dessa pessoa e se
comparamos isso com crianças que não
use esses princípios
neurocientistas aqui temos
exatamente os mesmos dados acima
agrupar dados onde a linha verde
e meio que cerca de três momentos vemos
que para mais pessoas pode ser
tremendamente benéfico incorporamos
esses princípios esses princípios apenas
conseguimos falhar em dois vídeos
portanto para mim já concluiu aqui
óculos são para praticar e
desconto antes de nossos hospitais
centros de reabilitação etc.
ferramentas muito úteis que podem mudar
para viver as pessoas para melhor no segundo
ponto
não planejamos em excesso temos que
fazer o que realmente queremos
altura
nós não pensamos muito lane onde eu quero
chegar porque quero defender aqueles
recursos bizarros travados reclamam
errático porque sem fim de certeza vamos
encontrar um desafio mais interessante e
se não jogarmos feito forçado
[Aplausos]